invité du 19/20 nathalie albert moretti
la rectrice de l'académie de dijon
bonsoir bonsoir on a entendu des
enseignants parfois s'inquiéter de cette
rentrée comment respecter les gestes
barrières les distances sociales partout
dans l'école un protocole leur a donné
c'est quand même un peu à leur
appréciation de gérer de la situation
permettez moi tout d'abord de leur
souhaiter à tous élèves et enseignants
la meilleure entrée possible
effectivement le protocole sanitaire
posé un certain nombre de principes tout
à fait robuste et permettant une
adaptation à tous les scénarii mais en
même temps chaque chef d'établissement à
la possibilité d'adapter au mieux à aux
particularités de ces locaux ou de ces
experts extérieurs les décisions et les
meilleures solutions et qui a protocole
assez strict en plusieurs pages mais il
ya quand même une petite marge de
manoeuvre
que se passe-t-il si il y à des cas
qu'ovide dans une école à partir de deux
cas en ferme alors non là on est
parfaitement prêt un protocole a été
pensé en lien avec la rs la préfecture
et donc les services du rectorat pour
imaginer tous les scénarii possibles et
être capable de tracer très très vite
les cas contact du cac au vide que l'on
espère pas concrètement à partir de
combien de cas on ferme vraiment où on
passe à quoi l'école à la maison où on
passe cela en fait ces jeunes sévèrement
du cas par cas
je peux pas vous dire c'est à partir de
un ou deux cas c'est du cas par cas en
fonction de la manière dont ça s'est
passé
la seule chose qui est important de
signaler aux parents pour les rassurer
c'est que en 48 heures on assure qu' ils
seront contactés et que la situation
sera traité ça peut être quoi quand la
maison pour l'enfant qui l'être
isolé ce sera l'école à la maison par
contre on espère ne fermer aucun
établissement aucune école des classes
probablement si les cas cowitz se
manifestent mais pas les établissements
et pas les écoles nord dans leur
intégralité
y at il des moyens supplémentaires pour
les enseignants remplaçants au cas où
des enseignants soit malade et absent
des classes alors si c'est dans le
premier degré on a des brigades de
remplaçant suffisante aujourd'hui qui
sont suffisantes et qui peuvent
intervenir très rapidement dans second
degré on applique les principes
habituels c'est à dire au delà de 15
jours avant un remplacement mais on a on
a les effectifs que les parents ne
s'inquiètent pas talonné par autre
inquiétude est ce que je peux amener mon
enfant juste que dans l'école pour un
petit qui fait sa première rentrée en
maternelle c'est dur de le laisser sur
le trottoir et dire des bretons avec
l'enseignante ne connaît pas qui est
masqué et je te laisse sur le trottoir
c'est un peu rude
le protocole ne l'interdît pas le choix
qui a été fait en général dans les
écoles c'est de privilégier les les
entrées à l'école c'est à dire les plus
petits ou le cp on est con élémentaire
bon ce qu'on peut demander aux parents
c'est de venir à 1 et peut devenir
parents parlaient pas les deux éviter
l'effet de masse pour éviter si tout se
passe bien si tout se passe bien pour
l'enfant on peut laisser tranquille
exactement
mais on a des renie pas dernière chose
sur les équipements en informatique avec
le confinement on a vu que beaucoup se
sont équipés d'ordinateurs est-ce que ça
avance dans l'académie alors on a fait
un énorme pas et là c'est vraiment le
moment de remercier les collectivités
locales pour leur aide puisque grâce à
elle que de foot oui beaucoup d'élèves
ont été dotés et ça va continuer encore
cette année de manière à juguler les
inégalités sociales
merci vraiment progresse à la rentrée
dans que demain on la souhaite
évidemment à tout le monde merci à vous
merci beaucoup